okay so I'm going to talk about a
framework that we have developed for
reconstructing into tumor fellow Chinese
I'm going to mostly skip the
introduction because we have heard it
not a couple of times just let me say
that we want to reconstruct this part of
the tree of the evolution so when we
started this project we got basically
inspired by this picture and this
picture is a is a tree which has been
constructed manually and the clones were
assembled by clustering frequencies and
they ended up with four clones but a
clustering scheme and then try to build
a tree and in the end they saw and the
scheme for building the tree was
basically a parent has to have high
frequency tender than the than a a
successor and if there are siblings than
the sum of them has to be lower than the
parent basically so they ended up with
this tree and then they saw that and
they also had some some reeds so it was
sequencing data where two mutations
would fall on one read so you could
actually see by mutual exclusivity if
those come from one clone or if they
come from from other from different
clones and then they basically had to
split up one of their clones into
actually three of them and they could
not they did not know where to attach
how much of this clone so basically by
this idea we started a this project and
we are looking to look at faced state
that we are not going to look at
frequencies but we want to look at fully
phased data because i think that the
phasing by frequency does not work that
well especially if you go in a bit lower
frequency ranges
so the idea is that we have a mixed
sample for example we have faced data
from it I'm going to talk about later
work that can be and we do not want to
build a tree like this a classical tree
but a differentiation hierarchy so
basically we want to know how much mass
and how much how big were the clones
that were early in the evolution as well
and we want to have a probabilistic
method for that so we started or we use
a tree-structured de Richelieu process
as a clustering prior as prior for
clustering that gives us first of all a
tree structure and second of all masses
attached to the notes and the leaves
that sum to 1 so the base is the perfect
setup for clustering for mixture
modeling we're going to place the data
in the nodes in internal nodes as well
as the trees and the nodes and beliefs
and the notes the internal nodes and the
leaves are going to correspond to clones
later this framework is very flexible
and it has incorporated a transition
kernel which basically gives you the
gives you prior probabilities on
parameters of nodes given their parent
nodes and this for us provides provides
us a link to classical felony or to
other prior knowledge that we have off
the data for example if we look at
methylation data which you're going to
do later their vacuum entation is
something that cannot be ruled out and
is even fairly common if we look at
single nucleotide variants back mutation
or multiple mutations are is something
that is relatively rare and we can sort
of try to rule it out in this transition
colonel we do in france by an mcmc
scheme which we sort of adapted from the
original author of this of this
clustering prior and we made it a bit
faster and we
we have more effective way of a sampling
over the topology space but I'm not
going to go into this we tried to
evaluate the performance based of this
master based on clustering and as well
as a summary statistics of the tree
topologies and we see that this method
gets better and better and has a higher
out performance with increasing levels
of error rates so now i'm going to show
you two examples two data sets that we
looked at one data set is from is from
colon cancer and another one is from
leukemia so the colon cancer data set
was that was bisulfite sequencing of one
locus that's the RX to locust it's a 201
base per locus and spends eight CPGs and
so the idea is basically that since
these methylations when they can get
transferred to daughter cells have a
very high error rate that this locus
basically can act as a molecular clock
for us it's also neutral in this in this
tissue it's not expressed the whole
region's basically off it's a very nice
molecular clock so we fit or we ran our
model and now i'm going to show you two
examples and we have multiple samples
per two month usually three to five from
the left side three to five from the
right side and here's one example and
here you can see what is the mass
associated with the first level of the
tree the second the third and the fourth
we can see in this example that the
right side of this tumor looks fairly
much the same in terms of tree topology
while the left the samples from the left
side have quite some variance we can see
the same effect if we look at summary
statistics from this tree like the
maximum tree depth as well as the the
total branch lengths that the right side
always cost is fairly nicely together
but
the left side divides into two parts
basically another example is from
another tumor here it's interesting that
if you look at summary statistics from
these trees like the total branch
lengths we can see that the left side
and the right side cluster together well
it works even better if we use
combinations of multiple summary
statistics like the maximum tree depth
and the number of clones we can really
see that that these two sides are
separate so the second example is going
to be from a leukemia and it was single
cell sequencing of whole exome
sequencing of 56 cells there was a very
high dropout rate and about 700 snv's
were identified and here we just plug
the basically a different model into a
transition kernel which encodes for
infinite sites model and the original
authors basically had a relatively
simple model and concluded from this
data that there was a monoclonal
evolution so what do we see we see also
a very strong sort of monoclonal arm of
this of this tree where they are like 34
+ 7 so 41 cells which is a good part of
the tumor is associated with this part
of the tree however we also see that
there is quite some branching coming
from an early stage of this tumor which
is still seen it at the final result of
this tumor so let me conclude so we have
this probabilistic model no for intro to
American sir Falacci knee reconstruction
in France since its mcmc is relatively
slow and needs to be should be faster
but one problem that we ran
and that we haven't solved and there's
an open problem I think is there is no
nice comparison method for this sort of
evolutionary trees so there is no
natural sort of distance function or
anything that's can sort of give a nice
score which sort of measures how similar
two of these trees are and by that I
want to finish up and acknowledge the
people who have contributed is Nico here
and Florian Markowitz and one of his
post x ke one and thank you for your
attention thank you please comment so
there's a number of methods to compare
ever also have to eat so why you why you
what you watch me see in those methods
so first Audrey they have masses
associated to the notes so that's
missing and the mass is associated to
the notes so and note weights yes and
also we have data inside the tree all
the the standard for three methods of
phylogenetic trees have all the data at
the leaf level but we don't have I don't
know because you have different
topologies you don't know how deep a for
example a specific clonus you need to
measure that and you need to sort of all
compress it into one square and there's
no natural way to do that I think
a question here ready long
sort of my you said that you are using
some probably because I'm probably some
probability construction gather
information about successor from the
parent or vice versa what is the kind of
what is that to ability most part from
the year using it depends on the data
set so one of the data sets the
methylation data set we basically just
had a occur under which said it is
relatively unlikely to have mutation
forward but a mutation backward has sort
of a similar probability that it can
happen for a for the snv's data we did
not encode the spec mutation or we had
like a much much lower probability for
back mutations is a great question about
the as Dana said a single-celled NSM the
creature she had compared to that the
method that he go talk about money if
you would run it on that was it the same
data set we mean that the world don't
quite some differences that don't we
call it every detail but no not exactly
the same of course in this method
estamos showed you you just are together
the clones a sort of the sequences
explicitly in to close that where is
living in the approach we don't do that
so anyway it's not i mean we saw tragic
of the apartment totally straightforward
vertices all the three have a different
interpretation in the two models so you
have to let them somehow onto each other
it seems on the surface okay okay thanks
again to us